Estoy aquí en la Escuela de Medicina de
Stanford, con Ill Gosun Tight, que es miembro
de la facultad de la escuela de medicina. -Hola,
Sal. -Entonces, ¿de qué vamos a hablar? Bueno,
el tema de hoy es la endocrinología, que es el
estudio de las hormonas, y la palabra "hormonas"
se deriva de la palabra griega que significa
estimular la actividad. Lo que hacen las hormonas
es que son mensajeros químicos que se producen en
una parte del cuerpo y, por lo general, van a otra
parte del cuerpo para, como su nombre lo indica,
estimular la actividad y hacer funcionar a otro
órgano. -Entonces, son esencialmente una especie
de señalización, una forma de comunicarse entre
una parte del cuerpo y otra. -Exactamente, son
comunicadores muy sofisticados. Creo que es un
término perfecto y creo que otra forma de pensarlo
es que nuestro cuerpo se comunica directamente de
alguna manera. Por ejemplo, los nervios inervan
el músculo y cuando lo quieres contraer das una
señal desde tu cerebro que baja por el nervio
y se une directamente al músculo y hace que se
contraiga. Mientras que las hormonas se parecen
más a la conexión Wi-fi del cuerpo humano:
son inalámbricas, se producen en un lugar,
entran en el torrente sanguíneo que es como
las ondas aéreas, por así decirlo, y luego
trabajan en otra parte del cuerpo a distancia,
sin conectarse directamente a esa parte del
cuerpo mecánicamente. -¿Y las hormonas son un
tipo específico de proteína o un tipo específico
de químico o son realmente cualquier cosa que haga
lo que acabas de describir? -Son prácticamente
cualquier cosa. Pero se dividen en dos categorías
principales: hay pequeñas moléculas que
generalmente derivan de aminoácidos y esas
moléculas miden de 300 a 500 daltons como
máximo, que son unidades de masa molecular;
y hay proteínas grandes que pueden tener un tamaño
de cientos y cientos de aminoácidos. -Ya veo,
entonces cualquier cosa que realmente tenga esta
función de señalización. -Así es, se consideraría
una hormona, y la otra cosa es que hablamos de
hormonas en tres tipos de subcategorías: llamamos
a algunas hormonas endocrinas, las cuales ingresan
al torrente sanguíneo y trabajan a gran distancia,
y daremos algunos ejemplos con tu diagrama en
un minuto. También hay otras cosas que se llaman
hormonas paracrinas, y las hormonas paracrinas son
más activas regionalmente, por lo tanto, podrían
producirse en una parte del cuerpo y trabajar a
una corta distancia de ese sitio de síntesis. Y
luego la tercera categoría que es menos común
serían las hormonas autocrinas, y las hormonas
autocrinas se producen directamente en una célula
y funcionan en esa misma célula o en la célula
que está justo al lado, a una distancia muy, muy
corta. -Ya veo. Entonces las hormonas endocrinas,
creo que tengo un modelo mental para ello, se
liberan en algún lugar lejos del cuerpo, y si son
recogidas por el receptor correcto realizarán la
función correcta. -Las hormonas paracrinas ¿tienen
un efecto reducido porque sólo pueden viajar una
distancia corta o es otra cosa? -Por lo general,
las hormonas paracrinas ingresan al torrente
sanguíneo, pero la concentración del receptor,
como tú sugieres, está muy cerca, lo que hace que
una hormona paracrina funcione regionalmente es
una alta concentración de receptores muy cerca
del sitio de síntesis. Y lo mismo sucede con las
autocrinas, se producen y hay una concentración
muy alta de receptores justo en esa célula o
justo al lado de ella. -Y esta podría ser una
pregunta tonta, pero se llama endocrinología,
¿hay paracrinólogos? -Bueno, es un buen
punto. No lo creo; creo que simplemente, tal
vez porque la función paracrina de las hormonas
se descubrió más tarde, todavía vemos todo esto
bajo el marco de la endocrinología. -Correcto,
entonces todas las hormonas son endocrinología,
aunque las hormonas endocrinas son las que actúan
a grandes distancias -Eso es correcto. Creo que es
una buena forma de resumirlo. Me gusta el diagrama
que dibujaste aquí porque ilustra algunos de los
principales órganos endocrinos, de los que
hablaremos en charlas posteriores. Entonces,
el primero que mostraste, muy bien, en la
cabeza, en la base del cerebro, es esa estructura
anaranjada que sería la glándula pituitaria y la
glándula pituitaria se le llama glándula maestra
porque desde la pituitaria producimos hormonas
que funcionan en otros órganos. Por ejemplo,
una de las hormonas que produce la pituitaria se
llama hormona estimulante de la tiroides o TSH,
y después de que abandona la pituitaria entra en
la circulación y actúa sobre la glándula tiroides,
donde hay alta concentración de receptores de
TSH en la superficie de las células tiroideas y
estimula la glándula tiroides para que produzca
hormonas tiroideas, típicamente tiroxina,
T4 o triyodotironina (T3). Éstas serían las
hormonas circulantes principales de la tiroides.
-¿Y qué hacen? -Regulan el metabolismo, regulan
el apetito, regula la termogénesis, regulan la
función muscular, tienen actividades generalizadas
en otras partes del cuerpo. -Pero regula de forma
ascendente o descendente todo el cuerpo y el
metabolismo. -Así es. Alguien con hipertiroidismo
tendría un metabolismo muy alto. Es posible
que conozcas la imagen clásica de alguien con
una frecuencia cardíaca alta, metabolismo
rápido y pérdida de peso, sería alguien
con cantidades excesivas de hormona tiroidea. Y
luego tenemos la imagen inversa: cuando alguien
tiene una deficiencia de hormona tiroidea,
alguien con hipotiroidismo, por lo tanto,
es fundamental mantener la cantidad justa de casi
todas estas hormonas, y las hormonas tiroideas son
buenos ejemplos de esto. Pero la regulación
final la realiza la glándula pituitaria. -Es
una especie de maestra: envía una señal allí y
luego esto hace el trabajo. -Eso es correcto,
y hablaremos más tarde sobre los circuitos de
retroalimentación, porque ¿cómo sabe la pituitaria
cuándo deja de producir TSH? Básicamente, como
un termostato, puede detectar los niveles de
hormona tiroidea, y cuando esos niveles están
en el nivel correcto, no demasiado altos,
disminuirá la cantidad de TSH que produce. Si los
niveles son demasiado bajos, aumentará la TSH para
tratar de estimular la glándula tiroides para que
produzca aún más hormona tiroidea. -Genial. ¿Y qué
más tenemos aquí? -Ok, algunas de las hormonas
principales. La pituitaria, además de producir
hormonas estimulantes de la tiroides, produce una
hormona llamada ACTH, hormona adrenocorticotropa
o corticotrofina suprarrenal, que actúa sobre
la corteza suprarrenal, y la suprarrenal es esa
glándula que se encuentra exactamente en la parte
superior del riñón; y las capas externas de la
glándula suprarrenal son la corteza suprarrenal y
son estimuladas por ACTH. -Y no están relacionadas
con el riñón, simplemente se encuentran allá
arriba, están estructuralmente allí. -Correcto,
están relacionadas sólo en el sentido de que el
suministro de sangre es rico como el suministro
de sangre de los riñones y se encuentran arriba
de los riñones. Se llaman suprarrenales porque
están en la parte superior del riñón. -Eso debería
haber sido obvio, nunca me di cuenta de eso. -Pero
no filtran la sangre ni realizan ninguna de las
funciones claves que cumple el riñón. -Ya veo,
¿y cuál es su papel? -Las glándulas suprarrenales
producen hormonas suprarrenales como el cortisol,
que regula el metabolismo de la glucosa
y es importante para mantener la presión
arterial y el bienestar. Y también produce
el mineralocorticoides como la aldosterona,
que es importante para regular el equilibrio de
sal y agua. También hay andrógenos suprarrenales
que son importantes. Y estas tres hormonas son
las principales hormonas producidas por la corteza
suprarrenal: la ACTH regula principalmente el
cortisol y los andrógenos suprarrenales, y hay
otro sistema que regula los mineralocorticoides,
del que hablaremos más adelante. -Muy bien y
tenemos algunos órganos más aquí . -Sí, también en
la pituitaria se producen la hormona luteinizante
y la hormona foliculoestimulante, que abreviamos
como LH y FSH, y éstas actúan sobre las gónadas:
en el hombre actuará en los testículos y en
la mujer actuará en los ovarios para estimular
respectivamente el desarrollo de esperma en
el hombre y los ovocitos u óvulos en la mujer;
y también la producción de esteroides gonadales,
principalmente testosterona en el hombre y
estradiol en la mujer. -Correcto. ¿Y nos estamos
olvidando de algo? -Bueno, hay otras dos hormonas
que también se derivan de la pituitaria anterior,
y una de esas sería la hormona del crecimiento,
que es crítica para el crecimiento óptimo de
los huesos largos. -La pituitaria realmente
hace mucho. -Lo hace. -Entonces, es HGH
la hormona del crecimiento humano. -Sí,
la hormona de crecimiento humano, y ésta actúa en
los huesos largos. Y luego tenemos la prolactina,
que es importante en las mujeres para la
lactancia, para poder amamantar después del
parto. -¿Y la insulina qué es? -La insulina
es clave, pero no proviene de la pituitaria,
así que ahora vamos a bajar un poco. Ya hablamos
sobre la glándula tiroides que produce la hormona
tiroidea y, luego, cuando llegamos al páncreas,
que es esta estructura amarilla justo en el medio,
dentro de él hay pequeñas islas llamadas
islotes de Langerhans, y los islotes dentro
del páncreas producen hormonas endocrinas como
la insulina y el glucagón. La insulina es vital,
sin insulina tienes diabetes, y sin insulina no
transportas glucosa al músculo ni eliminas la
glucosa del torrente sanguíneo normalmente. La
ausencia de insulina puede producir todos los
síntomas de diabetes, de los que hablaremos más
adelante. -Parece que, incluso estructuralmente,
tenemos el páncreas aquí mismo, tenemos
las glándulas suprarrenales también ahí,
todas están cerca de ese tipo de intercambio
porque es muy importante que todas lleguen
a donde necesitan llegar. -Esa es una buena
observación, todas tienen mucho drenaje venoso,
de modo que cuando producen su hormona ésta
ingresa al torrente sanguíneo con bastante
rapidez, porque son estructuras vitales. -Eso
es genial. Creo que podemos dejarlo allí,
y en el siguiente video tienes algunas fotos
que creo que serán bastante interesantes. -Ok,
sí, en el siguiente video hablaremos sobre lo
importante que es tener la cantidad correcta de
la hormona, o de lo contrario las cosas saldrían
mal. -Excelente, muchas gracias. -Ok, gracias.